oui bientôt monde s'excuse et on se
retrouve aujourd'hui pour une vidéo qui
va changer des autres puisque je
reprends comme vous aurez pu constater
dans les dents le cheat pardon les
épisodes de panique donc j'avais fait
trois ou quatre épisodes sur dead space
2 est bon j'avais arrêté car le jeu me
passionnait pas plus que ça vraiment bon
voilà après chacun son truc est donc là
j'ai décidé de faire de reprendre cette
série mais sur fear 3 parce qu'il paraît
que c'est un jeu où on se fait sacrément
4,4 sur faut bien dire et je dois dire
que là je me suis même mis dans le noir
bon là j'ai mis le mcb a subi neuf
thèmes et je peux vous dire que je suis
presque mange pas dans le noir je vois
quand même les objets mais il fait quand
même très sombre dans ma chambre c'est
pour avoir un peu plus peur et plus se
mettre dans l'ambiance
enfin bon c'est parti commando un pop up
ok on va mettre recrues on va mettre new
game
ok bah c'est parti je sens je sais pas
pourquoi je sens que je avoir peur mais
celui-là parce qu'il faut savoir que moi
pour ceux qui ne me connaissent pas je
suis vraiment une et lambda pc des
appels intro parce que ça en anglais
j'ai mis en anglais bref alors
good job en ennemi mouvement
on a dans l'excellent qu'elle y est j'ai
pas du tout joué aux autres il faut
savoir j'ai jugé juste calcul est oui
pourquoi ils thon rouge mais au [ __ ]
je connais pas du tout l'histoire ça
sent le roussi là ça sent le roussillon
et la broussaille
alors attendez ou la caisse et que cette
sensibilité de tarrier non mais non de
dieu machin alors on va vraiment drôle
non j'ai dit au bailliage mandat elle
alors bac
voilà bon c'est déjà mieux de façon je
prends trois qui aura besoin de trouver
de quoi trop de gens autour monde désolé
pour cette interruption
alors donc on peu court et il ya un
espèce défi de ce deus donc je découvre
complètement avec vous le jeu ans je
suis encore d'autres études sur ce jeu
mais je me suis dit soit les palais
quand même changé en peu de mots
j'ai quand même changer un peu de
l'ambiance plutôt de faire que du fun au
port [ __ ] mais gratuit
[ __ ] est là je vous avoue que je aulas
au [ __ ]
ouais ouais c'est bon là on a un peu au
monde jeu là c'est le look est d'avoir
amassé une carte sur un des mecs on va
juste un peu enrobé sa sensibilité je
vous promets j'arrive vraiment pas à
jouer en attendant va mettre en merde
à chaque fois je suis vraiment vous
voulez alors voilà voilà voilà qui est
bien alors où on doit aller et quand
quelques chutes weapon 10,3 à wake est
d'accord donc faux péter le lac avec ça
alors apparemment il était emprisonné
tous les deux lui est le mec on a vu au
début donc la fois blessure cuisse et
kz2 machin qu aux [ __ ] moi avons
acquis un mais comment on fait tu as
ouais c'est un nom à yuki c'est juste
pour se protéger mais on s'en fout mais
on s'en fout
voilà ok fallait courait sauter alors ok
un levier à mai
hop tu as ta grosse mer il est là et il
va vous baisez alors alors oh là là au
monsieur je veux augmenter ils sont
comme un [ __ ] pour être encore plus
dans l'ambiance
waouh cf oh mon dieu pourquoi j'ai voulu
faire le jeu vous pourrez vous inspire
pas vite marion mais en plus je connais
pas du tout les hommes si vous pouvez me
dire dans les commentaires un peu
quelques histoires quoi parce que je
connais vraiment mais absolument pas
l'histoire ça c'est vraiment aux singes
et 36 ça c'est quoi des rats et tout mon
dieu un peu en plus j ai vu un gain plus
de ça on m'avait envoyé une vidéo me dit
mais montrant ça justement un [ __ ]
mais chez j c'est un frêche boccace au
[ __ ] aller job au monde je vous
promets sait vraiment mais encore là je
commente avec vous c'est comme si vous
étiez avec moi nous donc ça va en plus
c'est un effet de dézoomer monstrueux
quand bon compte
f or je sais pas pourquoi ils sont
soupçonnés je sais que j'ai une fille je
sais mais plus qui sait dans l'histoire
qui fait vachement peur et tout haut
o comment s'était tiré je suis choqué
ouais bon fps et montrer car vous allez
prendre cher alors vraiment pour
l'histoire je tiens vraiment si vous
marquez les trucs dans les commentaires
puisque je connais vraiment mais pas du
tout une feinte rouges avaient acquis
ses lettres en voyant que je suis en
tout cas d'espèce de à la glissade foire
et céda c'est marrant alors attendez
parce que franchement quand je vous dis
que je mets mes cm à s'allier louis tu
montes sur son ordi les gens et en mode
pas content qu avatar l'artois yamakasi
mer c'est bien un sujet bien c'était
fait de la traîner des balles comme ça
qu'un chef passé sans voix or au niveau
des graphismes
y'a pas à chier le jeu haoues à activer
le a mais c'est moi en fait qu'activer
ça sans faire exprès tout à l'heure en
blanc macro cuillère 1-1 d'accord donc
soit sincèrement tous à petit à petit
bond à olalalala mais moi je croyais que
c'était un jeu ou fallait se balader
chialer quoi
un jour il ya deux ans en action
apparemment la fosse échapper façon au
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] ça c'est un coup bas il ya les
chinois qui vous attendent dans
l'hérault banques pour vous couper la
gorge
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
c'est quoi ça t'es quoi toi hein
oh allez dégage voilà à alger c'est
affreux alors on lui a il a un temps de
l'action lui sur colloque qui serait
vachement bon quoi le mec à peine je
dirais tu que se passe-t-il il te
démontrer d'accord y'a voilà jaoui c'est
franchement ce du système de ralenti je
dois avouer que j'accroche bien c'est
vraiment sympa
bah vous n'êtes pas trop nombreux dans
tranquillement à 40 contre 1 voix oui
d'accord
adacore ans j'adore
oh je vous promets que je vais tomber
amoureux de ce machin et pourquoi on est
emprisonné mais c'est super stressant
j'aurais dû à un peu me renseigner sur
l'histoire du jeu même si je laisse ça
me passionne pas vraiment de d'accord le
mentionner sur l'histoire d'un jeu
pareil enfin pourquoi qu'est ce qui a
relégué ce qui s'est passé au mac et la
petite fille ces questions principales
j'aimerais bien savoir
bon allez on va se barrer on va monter
en haut pour leur péter la tronche mais
franchement je j'avoue que là juste mes
impressions ça fait peur nous et c'est
l'impasse en cours et mans mais
totalement youtube c'est un peu logique
même
mais bon j'ai mis en mode facile et ça
se voit je mentionne le mode facile ne
cherche pas le niveau de peur je pense
on n'est pas là pour jouer comme des
gros tarés un fps à twitter aux
destinées de combourg nuit au ralenti
hop
ouah ouah je peux vous dire qu'il ya
quand même de l'action vous voyez ça tu
vois je enfin vous voyez pas bon ça tu
vois ça a fait rire toi
j'aurais jamais pensé que leurs
transactions dans un jeu comme ça même
waouh [ __ ] j'ai cru voir un truc
bouger alors on continue
allez c'est pas de là où je viens ou là
pourquoi il ya autant d'un [ __ ]
locked
ouais d'accord ce cas ce qu'est ce qu'on
fait on peut pas descendre plus il ya un
espèce de buzzer en arrière fond qui
super chiant et je dois bien le dire ça
c'est chiant entendre je vous l'avouer
bon alors il ya sûrement un truc à
fermer un ok d'accord l'hôtel salé à
posséder des canettes mais ça va bien
quoi ça va bien tu pourrais passer des
choses plus intéressantes
je rêve ou non j'ai cru qu'on pouvait
sépare affreuse
on sait pas ce qui se cache derrière
aurait à bompas encore monter serait ce
donc par là d'accord des armes des
grenades et tout prix d'un et pourquoi
et c'est je sais pas il ya des objets
qui volent mais qui sont des objets
totalement inutile à ya encore un qu'un
truc là-bas
bizarre ou alors s'il y en a parmi vous
qui sont fans de survival horror
j'attends vraiment tu veux me racontiez
un peu c'est l'histoire du jeu et je
dois vous dire que franchement si je si
je fais un truc sur ça c'est fou
oui oui oui j'arrive j'arrive c'est
franchement pour vous hein parce que
alors là j'aurais vraiment jamais - moi
même franchement nous mêmes d'espèces de
là quand j'ai joué c'était uniquement en
vidéo je jouerai jamais à des jeux aussi
flippant que ça tout seul ja je vois pas
l'intérêt à part des petites montré dans
des petites montées d'arrêt par don
d'être voit un jeu bon voilà ap
associated press voilà c'est bon alors
on a apparemment il ya un shotgun perso
je suis pas vraiment fan des survols en
or à ce point là a d'accord ok alors
pour ceux qui connaissent le jeu ça a dû
bien les saouler que
ils ont très cher la fougueuse salue
déjà pourquoi ces gens veulent me tuer
alors qu'à une petite fille qui
apparemment vous pétez agrochimie encore
c'est un peu des archers pardon mais
plutôt celle des contrées le point de
jeu doit dire des conneries certainement
que ce que je trouvais pas le jeu créé
ce bordel 1 s'est noyé c'est une boutade
up harricana les ennemis résidera mon
serment du bain de sang et du gore à
mort j'ai vu qu'il ya des défis en bas à
gauche la haute à la ola
mais ça craint là dedans nous mêmes
comment eux mêmes peuvent travailler
mais c'est quoi ce machin en plus donc
dieu c'est vraiment flippant quoi [ __ ]
j'suis sur un joueur je me retournais il
y aura un gros screamer et je vais pas
aller on tente
j'ai pas envie de voir j'ai pas envie de
voir alors y'a personne adhère la vie
[ __ ] c'est flippant alors temps mais
cette ambiance mais un oh mon dieu oh
mon dieu la disparue les plus le mec il
ya deux on est d'accord il y avait bien
un bonhomme a été comme ça part mal je
crève
c'est tout simplement mais abominable
jeu franchement je le peux vous dire en
plus vous voyez pas très bien je suis
désolé si vous voyez pas très bien ma
tête mais alors [ __ ] t'as pas une clé
toi waouh wade était plus par là bas
mais où faut aller ça par contre j'aime
pas ça dans les jeux des forfaits voilà
un autre hall à la mêlée le mec mais
aract et après ça ils sont cons quoi on
devrait s'allier contre ce machin
bizarre bon après je dise ah bon c'est
vrai que ça doit vous énervez pour ceux
qui sont fans de la série
je m'excuse d'avancé j'ai offensé votre
jeu favori mais alors vraiment mais
qu'est ce que ça fait peur quand je
poursuis pour ce conte pas peur devant
ça qu'on les joue tout seul dans un peu
dans le noir ta mère je sais pas juste
pas qu'on les prend sincèrement je sais
absolument pas comment ils font ça sent
le jacques ça s'en vient
c'est sympa c'est en fait à chaque
ouverture de porte faux laisse-moi mbaye
la maison vraiment plein de vie quoi bon
vous me direz moi j'en ai d'emploi
précis je dépense le bal gratuitement on
c'est un lieu qui fait peur ou un jeu
d'action là moi j'attends moi la peur
j'ai pas eu peur depuis début mai
fragile comme celle de brinon pool sud
alors par contre au niveau des défis là
qu'on a vu tout à l'heure on tue des
gens mais ça va ça va ya toute une armée
non comment on lance une grenade
waouh
ça va je ne sais pas 300 g non on va
attendre deux minutes que je sais pas ça
se régénère ou quoi c'est parti
bam bam bam bam bam comme envoyer entre
équipe est au fond un magnifique
magnifique je sais pas comment ils font
dans les jeux pour faire de même en
dessous motion comme ça ça doit être un
algorithme de niveau b 6 puis 10 h 4 6
mais franchement mais comment on peut
avoir comme x men et non juste les gens
qui développe le jeu imaginé comme ils
doivent juste eux mêmes se chier dessus
quand ils font des trucs du genre il ya
un espèce de gros sous ouais bon là
c'est l'arrière général apparemment des
s'échapper de l'ag pas très bien compris
le mec rouge que abu dhabi je sais pas
alors je comprend un bon vous dire
sincèrement je comprends absolument pas
l'histoire
je suis vraiment pas bonne je kiffais
pas comme je voulais j'ai cette fois on
va pas se faire baiser on se faire trois
tours de la fin alors qu'elle buvait du
foot mayotte au dessus qu'est ce que ça
a changé
voilà bah on était sûr je n'accable pas
la luge est infoutue réflexe de strapper
comme ça c'est les années sur
counter-strike jeu sera automatiquement
maintenant
dodgers après je ne sais pas pourquoi
mais et on se fait un petit moment au
liban
non non non
c'était beau franchement c'est évident
alors
voilà donc là j'ai un défi par exemple
fallait vider à la charge de alors ça
aussi qu'est-ce qu'il fait léser clic
ça donne des points ok mais encore à
quoi ça sert voilà je sens le chien âge
dans le cas sont profondément je parie
que ça va faire peur c'est bien des
missions de - chance à ouais c'est ça
alors là oh merde y'a pas un petit bonus
ça va oh là là là là mais comme ces
blogs
ah c'est quoi ça oh [ __ ] on met même
c'est glauque au la rancoeur à haga des
niveaux tam et touchant je ne comprends
plus je ne suis plus
ah oui on peut cliquer genre assez mal
faits doit traiter ma mère abandonnée
c'est un peu bête femmes ont peut-être
ici way
avery j'ai bien fait aux [ __ ]
d'accord alors là c'était l'aspect
action de jeu maintenant c'est
l'expliqué rares o my god oh my god oh
what the fuck on arrive dans le
l'endroit un corps du machin oh [ __ ]
oh là là là là mais en plus j'ai joué
que son méga fort [ __ ] au [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
arrêtez avec vos musiques sonneurs qui
font peur
saving all à la wac excuse ohlala mais
si je dois affronter ce à un moment dans
je crois je pète un câble je vais vous
dire je vais juste pété un câble
makaay what the fuck ok je suis censé
faire quoi je peux pas m'en passer par
la csn
we've got problème qu'hier ils ont des
problèmes et
moi je suis mayol l'a1 est ici se passe
qu'est ce que c'est que cette merde mais
mes [ __ ] bon bah j'ai plus qu'à
lancer une grenade a même pied pour
crever je crois bien ouais bon d'accord
on va l'écouter jackie chan ils servent
à quoi
[ __ ] oh mon pauvre tu bois tu bol non
je te sauverait pas donc tu veux ou tu
veux que j'abrège allez hop gens mangent
pas mais j'ai déjà voyagé
voilà bon c'est c'est flippant
voilà on sort du machin oh lalala lalala
massager cette mission c'est ça qui est
impressionnant c'est un super longtemps
les aliments vol mais ce qui se présente
c'est de ne pas savoir pourquoi ils m'en
veulent quoi les mines croce en fin de
l'histoire est qu'il n'est pas sûr non
ça je ne prends pas un jeu je n'étais
pas dans l'habitude ce que je voulais
dire je n'en doute pas voilà mais là
autant pour moi qui ne connais vraiment
strictement rien je veux c'est pouvoir
ouais quoi là tu vois la tête haute
match
oh ça va bien là oh là là mais c'est un
jeu qui fait peur ou quoi voilà mon dieu
mais pourquoi j'ai eu l'idée de
reprendre les compagnies c'est vraiment
mais kelly chaude et casse toi il a
voulu jouer à ça alors là il m'a mis une
claque je leur mets désolé mais là je
vais juste crever
on prend rien lui sont bons salut alors
ça en fait c'est ce qui fait lever la
pop a vraiment je ne sais pas trop quoi
a peut-être que quand on est dans le
noir est qu'on n'a pas de lumière ou je
ne sais pas trop quoi ça fait quelque
chose
c'est parti
oh là là là mais quel actions de malades
lesquels action de folie mais c'est
l'âme c'est valable que les faits
aujourd'hui bon toi je te laisse rien à
[ __ ]
d'accord c'est vraiment là c'est que ça
latifi qu'on voit à chaque fois où
l'espèce de blum tu vas tronquoy attaque
d'un coup et que ici ils fassent ok
désolé d'avoir voulu piquer c'est un
chien n'ont jamais votre chien mon
moteur
ok ok j'existe on parle on en veut deux
moutures
c'est quoi ça des fois ya comme une
odeur à l'écran mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ça mais c'est ouf ça m'échappe pas
que c'est le one shot et c'est quoi ça
c'est au logement
je voudrais froid et des fruits
aujourd hui j ai peut-être j'espère
qu'elle va nous revenir
m
un volet à oui d'accord tu tombes hockey
de petites animations du tome aux
oubliettes
ouais aux oyats le mont rouge qui nous
sommes et c'est qui lui
c'est qu'ils lui en plus
d'accord
imaginez les mecs fait je crois c'est
simple les mecs ont créé le jeu auquel
ils doivent être doivent être un genre
la lega jamais avoir peur quand est ce
qu'on doit absolument rien à refaire
c'est fou franchement c'est fou et ben
voilà et ben voilà on a fini la première
mission à 12h19 voilà donc bah ça va
faire le président a fini
regardez la vidéo en tout cas j'espère
que cette première épisode vous aura plu
et que cette idée de reprendre les
donnes panique vous plaît alors on
attend d'en voir la fin de vidéo comme
ça j'espère qu'ils ne vous aura plu en
tout cas moi ça me plaît pas mais ça me
fait surtout très peur les death mais
c'était quand même vachement peur je
dois bien le dire les d'espèce les fiers
ça fait quand même bien peur c'est vrai
que c'est une ambiance différente de
celle des spectateurs mais ça fait bien
peur c'est un peu pareil koala des sauf
dans les spéciales qui est vraiment tout
c'est alors que l'homme - je crois que
ces êtres humains ce que je suis pas sûr
mais je crois enfin bon ça fait bien peu
en tout cas c'est tout ce que je retiens
firent fait peur et où aller on se
retrouve bientôt pour une nouvelle vidéo
chat ou le monde bail